let's bring in sir ed davey who is
joining us now hello to uh thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
um
you heard what the chancellor said uh
yesterday welcome to our hometown of
wigan by the way what did you make of it
i just don't think he's doing anywhere
near enough he doesn't seem to get it
there are millions of families and
pensions who are hurting now
and we've seen a government that's first
of all not done enough and then it's
dithering and delaying
and they've got to do something now
i'm really worried okay that um people
out there are getting more and more
anxious about the future they've heard
that this is going to get worse that we
could be entering a recession
the energy bills will go further in the
autumn and they have a government that
seems tone deaf
can't hear very well sir ed but we'll
plow on for now i'm sure we can sort
that out uh you want a cutting v80 the
argument is that cutting v80 only
benefits those who earn a lot of money
because they can afford more expensive
stuff and they get a better deal
that's simply not true
um as a portion of income it helps
people who are less well off it helps
cut motoring bills it helps cut food
bills it also helps cut the rate of
inflation
and it helps small businesses who are
struggling on the high street is exactly
the right thing to do
and we would pay for it by a windfall
tax on the oil and gas companies so we
would deliver a tax cut of 600 pounds to
the average family that's exactly what
is needed it's bold in it uh dramatic uh
i'm proud that the liberal democrats are
putting forward a constructive
positive proposal i just hope the
conservatives listen for once
what's the benefit of doing that rather
than
upgrading benefits
well there's room to do both we've uh
also argued that there needs to be some
target to help on the less well-off and
on pensioners we've talked about the
warm home discount which is money that
comes directly off people's energy bills
that should have been increased it
should be available to more people
and we've talked about the winter fuel
allowance i mean the government are seen
to be attacking pensioners at the moment
first of all they've reneged on the
election promise of the triple lock
which is costing bench and pensioners
billions of pounds then they failed to
up
rate pension pensions uh by the rate by
the real rate of inflation so
inflation's going up by nine percent
pensions only going up by three percent
this is a wholesale conservative attack
on pensioners and it's not not right
it's not acceptable
what about we were chatting to the mayor
of greater manchester earlier on in the
week and he was talking about a
universal basic income
good idea
well um the party my party has looked at
that and we're gonna
produce our our conclusions there are
quite a few other alternatives and in
the short term of course it couldn't be
introduced in the the short term you
need to look at things like the warm
home discount universal credit the
winter fuel allowance and this v80 tax
cut these are the measures that liberal
democrats want to do uh and uh they're
the ones we're focusing in on
talk to me about i think it's gonna be
the 23rd of uh june for the uh next uh
by-election that's what we're being told
not yet confirmed i'm sure that we'll
hear about that later on today hearing
more about a lib lab packed is that on
the cards
uh
absolutely not on the cards and it's not
happening what we're doing in the tifton
the honorton by-election
is talking about issues that matter to
people in that area and they're quite
similar actually to the issues in north
shropshire a by-election where we beat
the conservatives uh last december seek
the conservative health for 200 years
and we saw lifelong conservatives
fed up of boris johnson feeling taken
for granted by the conservatives
switching to the liberal democrats and
they were switching because of the
health service you know difficulty
getting uh appointments with gp sort of
too few gps long waits for ambulances
that are getting delayed because the
conservatives have failed to manage our
ambulances properly and then the cost of
living that really is coming up in the
doorsteps already and there's a rural
dimension to that uh you know k um in
many rural areas the key thing that
people depend on for heating their homes
is heating oil and lpg these are two
types of heating sources that aren't
regulated by off-gen there's no price
cap on them and the prices for heating
oil and lpg have gone through the roof
so rural households
including rural pensioners people in
rural poverty are really being hit
because the government just ignored them
taking them for granted so liberal
democrats will be talking about health
we'll be talking about the cost of
living and we'll be talking about
farmers who as i raised with the prime
minister yesterday um are absolutely
being betrayed by the conservatives we
need the farmers to help families and
pensioners with the cost of living with
the cost of putting food on the table
but the conservatives are making it more
difficult for farmers to play that role
what is i mean we've been here all week
we've been hearing about the livelihoods
and lifestyle of the people here in
wigan and the greater northwest region
why you did really well in in the local
council elections of course why do you
think you don't cut through
in regions like this
well i think we increasingly are cutting
through i mean in the last 12 months uh
it's been really clear that the liberal
democrats are the main challenges to
conservatives in many parts of the
country we have the by-election victory
uh in true blue buckinghamshire cheshire
ambition we have the by-election victory
that i talked about a minute ago in
north shropshire and our local election
results across the country from cumbria
to somerset from hull against labor uh
to many other parts of the country they
were the best of any political party so
i think people are listening to the
liberal democrats we're listening to
them we're listening to their concerns
and i think they like the fact that
there's a party that is taking up their
concerns with with constructive positive
alternatives the conservatives are just
taking them for granted ignoring them
sorry to interrupt you there sir ed talk
to me about what's going on uh with the
culture of the palace of westminster at
the moment 50 odd mps are presently
being investigated one has been arrested
on allegations of rape and yet still he
hasn't had the whip removed should that
happen and also was speaking to labour
yesterday they were saying that it needs
to be a more
rigorous uh selection process what do
you think
i think it is utterly shocking
there are some mps who are behaving
outrageously and wrong and they need to
be punished
uh
your viewers if they behaved
uh in their workplaces uh in the way
that some mps are behaving they would
lose their jobs and of course the whip
should be removed i it shouldn't even be
a question
um now you know he can be suspended you
know if he's
he didn't even need to be a due process
i believe in the process of law um but
in the meantime during these
investigations the extremely serious
allegations of course the whip should be
uh removed and i can't believe the
conservative side yet again
dragging their feet when one of their
own has broken the law this is becoming
a theme and maybe it's because the prime
minister
uh breaks the law and lies about it and
gets away with it
it's a prime minister's created a
culture particularly in the conservative
party and this is setting a very bad
example for the country for our young
people the prime minister frankly i you
know okay i've called for him to resign
but i don't believe he's a decent person
he's not a decent person to be the prime
minister of our great country and i
think true patriots
would want him to go so this whole
culture
you know that it rots from the top
sometimes a fish rots from its head and
if i think if we got rid of the prime
minister it will be a big step forward
and beginning to address some of these
problems
so just to clarify your suggestion that
it's a culture from the prime minister
downwards within the conservative party
within the government which means that
some feel allegedly that it's okay to
behave in a what is not a satisfactory
in any way manner for the rest of the
i
country
individual mps individual people need to
take responsibility for their wrongdoing
um let's be clear
however
if you have a culture from the top
where law breaking is seen to be okay
you'll get people away with it i mean
let me give you another example there's
so many
the home secretary pretty patel was
found guilty of bullying her staff
by the independent advisor on
ministerial standards who recommended
action should be taken
the prime minister refused to act
against his home secretary despite the
fact there'd been an independent inquiry
that she had bullied her staff
she's still in place
and at least the inter independent
advisor minister of standards had the
decency to resign because the prime
minister
failed to follow those recommendations
so this is why i say
this conservative prime minister boris
johnson is not fit to lead our country
he breaks the law
he allows his mates to get away with
joining us on the program yeah
sorry sir ed we must leave it there
sorry again to interrupt thank you for
joining us on the program this morning